[Music]
hey guys welcome to winners on a
Wednesday this week we have Chris and
Emma and we're gonna be introduced them
on now and hearing little about their
stories so welcome to the show guys
thank you so much for coming down it's
for have a nice yeah so you just just a
little bit of a nutshell I know you're
an IT consultant yeah you've been your
own street food business and you have
been deciding where to invest yeah I had
to get a safety net and financial
security you've decided property it's
going pretty well so far
yeah congratulations on your and your
two deals that you've done
thanks so much yes so why don't you give
us a little bit of background about why
why property well I was a contractor and
in IT got to a point in my career where
I didn't really feel like it could be
anything anything else not just kind of
searching for our next challenge and
then I happen to across the Robert
Kiyosaki on YouTube so haha so when you
say you were searching for your next
challenge what did you type in YouTube
did you type what we're looking for I
can't remember you know I literally just
like having a little having a browse
around because there's so many IT
consultants that are on the Academy yeah
and it's just it's crazy it's just but I
mean like continue I'm really interested
yeah we were looking at Robert Kiyosaki
and then your video we just thanks to
him I was like this guy looks young I
think looks interesting I'll click on
that yeah and yeah that was that was
early January June or something like
that and loved all your videos and then
kind of went on a different education
path but it's not kind of it's not kind
of what I thought it was and then one of
my friends Scott he was like we need to
go to this crash course oh no I've got
to on the crash course sorry and then
Scott was like I really want to come to
I was like yes let's do it
let's go do it this guy is awesome he's
got so much great energy and yo came to
this crash course and the amount of like
free information you get away on that
those two days just blew us away and I
was just like this guy's amazing we try
it we try our best
yeah and so after the crash course cuz
how long
you've been together I know you met and
on a boat some I see it yeah so what did
you think then when when when Chris told
you that he was going on this crash
course what was your what were you
thinking you saved up all your life to
buy one house I didn't understand all
these different avenues so I just kind
of just let me get on with it yeah yeah
it was just absolutely wasn't from it
and then he signed me up to the Academy
I watched some of your videos and loved
the energy and you know like your
approach to it yes
so really the same as Chris yeah cuz you
came down to your first Academy me last
week dance yes yeah
the lead generation tell us tell us
about what happened oh my gosh it was
well I I do a lot of meetings with the
contracting so it was it was it was kind
of nice to like see what other people
and things like that but then you were
surprised by a question or any area was
just blue blue your way and oh yeah cuz
you asked me a question didn't you I was
it you guys you asked me use that yeah
we spoke didn't wait the odium about was
it was it you guys
yes yeah yeah about about how to get
more deals yeah that's right you know so
you chose property you wanted to go on a
new challenge and you chose you came
down to the crash course I know you look
to other avenues Chris you were looking
at different business ideas you know
stocks and shares and things what was it
that made property to feel like the most
safest and securest way to invest your
money and literally just everything made
sense you you know put your money in and
it turned your you have an asset that
then you then live off instead of having
liabilities because you know like I
always thought you put money into a
house and you should get a mortgage and
that's a way of saving up some money and
but then you know what we keep SEC uses
a liability and it's really that cash
flow quadrant that really made me think
okay yeah this is this is the way to go
you it seems just absolutely make sense
yes yeah yeah great okay so tell me
about the two deals that you've secured
and how much profit you expecting to get
from them and also how much money you
put down so the first one we shoot it
was a it's a tuba department in in
Liverpool and it's
we should make about grand and a half
every month on on cash flow and that's
profit right yeah that's profit yeah Wow
I mean for a lot of people that's I know
you do very well in your business and as
an IT consultant but 1,500 pounds clean
profit a month that's it that's
life-changing yeah and that's and that's
every month first yeah passive yes this
is based our numbers are based on you
know January which is quite time of the
year anyway so yeah maybe even maybe
even bear cuz I know you're you're quite
conservative in your approach you do
that a lot of number crunching before
before the property so how much money
did you put into that deal because if I
know before you answer that question I
know you had a pot of money yeah you
know you do you're only very good money
as an IT consultant yeah you have a pot
of money not humungous but certainly
enough to buy one or two properties yeah
and you had a property a buy-to-let
going through which you chose to pull
out of it yeah and you didn't want to
invest in property instead you chose to
be invested into a serviced
accommodation business yeah that's right
so what was the reasoning behind that
so yeah you had a chunk of money but
when you're putting into property that
chunk you know disappears very fast and
a few problems here and there and you
know can really you know eat into that
so I was like whoa I need I need another
sort of form of investing into property
I've got my business the IT consultancy
business have am a street food business
putting money into those properties but
really if something if we could get
something else going we could make that
even faster yeah so I've decided to use
split that money up into smaller chunks
and to put into separate deals mentoring
why so we rent a service accommodation
is what you've done yeah and what's your
target how much money do you want to be
making all the time you finish the
Academy how much profit per year are you
hoping to be making well it took
completely just about a hundred fifty
thousand pounds sure which is a lot of
money yeah one hundred and fifty
thousand pounds per year every year yeah
pretty much passive yeah that's the
dream right yeah yeah that's the idea so
that might be a combination of these
went to essays and also putting the
money into you know like by totes and
HMOs and think yeah but yeah that's the
ultimate goal
so you second property registers
accommodation yeah how much is that
making so that will be making about a
thousand pounds maybe a little bit more
like that one's a lot quicker to set up
that one's more of that sort of ideal
service accommodation that you teach on
your course yeah but it's pretty much
good to go straight away yeah
so we've hard yet to do anything to that
one we just bought a TV some plants and
things like that and you're you're going
to a property - no I want you as well
yeah yeah and so how full-on were you at
the moment in property is it very much
hands-on at the moment everything yeah
every spare second we get we are I'm
like I wake up I'm like on my phone
making it to do this for the morning
yeah say my day out and then I'm off
literally in my breaks like that because
if you've got a big goal if you want to
break in 150,000 pounds cash you know
clean profit every year you've got to
put a lot of work in to get that it
doesn't it doesn't happen by accident
yeah and we both love it we're having a
great time so yeah it's enjoyable
together yeah yeah yeah I mean I think
if you live and breathe property and and
you absolutely love it it might be a few
months or a few years but at some point
you'll then be able to do whatever you
want whenever you want the yeah
absolutely and I mean the fact that
you've already in such a short amount of
time I mean when did you when did you
join the Academy just four weeks ago so
four weeks and you've got these two
these two deals I mean I know you did
the deal finding extravaganza yeah when
was that that was the same time we
joined the Academy we joined on there so
any a month ago yeah yeah Wow so it's
really really recent yeah it's
incredible cuz I feel like you've been
in the in the in the family for much
longer than that
oh yeah yeah we might probably have been
in the Facebook group yeah maybe so you
know you've read them well so so of the
two properties you maintain what maybe
three 3,000 or so to three to a half
thousand pound a month so how much
did you have to put down in order to get
that kind of return so the second one
that one that went straight out and it
was which to go not really much really
maybe about 300 parently 500 pounds with
the TV not a lot at all no no I'm not
money actually for an upfront rent yeah
upfront event so maybe like a granted
half of that and so 2 grand in total
deposit that's excluded deposit okay
fees to agents you maybe know to another
200 on top of that so two thousand two
hundred okay so so so so maybe about two
and a half thousand or just under yeah
but then to be making you'll make that
back within a month or so yeah exactly
yeah so I'll my target for but I'll
target for been to SATs to if we put any
money into have made that back within
six months yes absolutely
yeah yeah so talk to me about because I
know there's a lot every man who's dog
at the moment is wanted to do read to
serviced accommodation and it kind of
worries me actually guys because people
don't have they don't have the correct
training they they're not registered or
or legally set up that they're just
running out taking on apartments all
over the place yeah and then and then
sticking them on Airbnb and what's
happening is they're not when turnout
yeah and their guests aren't booking on
you're in the wrong areas they just do
it completely wrong and in trying to
make a quick buck because I believe that
serviced accommodation it's a business
and is to be taken seriously yeah I know
you've did a lot of research and you
spent a lot of you didn't just you took
action but it's always the balancing act
between between getting the knowledge
and then taking actions some people try
to get the knowledge forever and they
never take action other people take
massive action without the knowledge and
both are very dangerous so talk to me
about some of the research that you did
before you took these properties on and
the setting up on side of things and the
due diligence talk to me about all that
kind of stuff so so really we're looking
at local power teams so like cleaners
getting you insurance all that sort of
stuff for the demand side of things
we're looking on Airbnb
booking.com some like you were saying
some some areas that you think might
work really don't work cuz you found
some ones that looked you could very
easily on paper show the pictures you
know those ones that you found where
were they nearly yeah and you think
there'd be brilliant absolutely sunny
and property to me thinking this is the
perfect place you know right by the
docks view to the docks how could this
not work and then you start doing your
due diligence and yeah they just don't
work yeah why is that yeah II think so
yeah they like it maybe it's like a 2025
minute walk out and that little bit of
extra walking distance you know people
could go and pay roughly the same price
for maybe a slightly worse yeah property
yeah just like something a bit closer so
really location is is hugely important
yeah okay
so so so you do you deduce to find out
the market research power team talk to
me about power team because I think that
is I mean I see people doing red service
accommodation but then they end up yeah
not having their what power team and
then they're having to get you know
leave their house all kinds of crazy
times go and let people in and then ends
up becoming a job really yes I know is
completely not what you've done
yeah talk to me about how you managed to
find the power team members and who
those people consist of so really few
recommendations just asking other
members of the Academy or other property
investors we've met so one of them was a
great cleaner we found it really hard to
find a good cleaner in yeah in the
Republic we've Minister that's great
lady called Helen and then the the
management taking the keys so we we we
started using key nest which is which is
going really well
what why did you use key nest as opposed
to you put in a key safe outside just
one of the properties was I had a key
fob yeah on yet the entrance so you
could literally they couldn't get to the
the key safe yeah and we didn't want to
we didn't want to put a key safe on the
outside near some railings just thought
it made do you want to like piss off the
management company or anything yeah and
he might not be safe exactly yeah and
then someone who's got a key and they
could get in and they
if all they gotta do is try you know
some the pumps and then they're in so
it's these little tricks and tips isn't
it that a lot of people could think oh I
can't quite a key self outside therefore
I can't I can't run this as a rent to
serviced accommodation property yeah
tell us about key nest and what they do
because I think it's a fantastic service
if you get if I know they don't
necessarily cater to every sit doesn't
work for every single property but talk
to us about what key nest are because I
think it's brilliant
today they have like a local they have
local keenest location so like a local
minima or maybe like 24/7 garage or
something like that you go there you
drop your keys off with a code and then
your your client comes in and you give
the client a code they tuck it into
their machine they get the keys and then
that they're in yeah yes pretty simple
charge like 20 pounds I think it's
pretty funny money yeah you just pass
small monthly fee and what they just
look after the key don't they in a
location it's nothing really and then
the grand scheme of things when you're
making that much profit it doesn't
matter what's been for you a map what's
been the biggest learning point through
getting these properties set up and
everything we've moved grips basically
checking everything when you're going to
view the property cuz I made the mistake
of point of view the first ones and not
just I won't do nothing oh my god I love
it but the first one I didn't the key
fob I didn't realize we needed to em
yesterday
oh yeah yeah just checking everything
over making sure everything's hundred
percent right yeah brilliant that's
great how about for you Chris what's
been the biggest learning point or
lessons if you if you were delighting
yourself a few months ago what would you
say we really like when people say look
at your goals and your where you want to
get to don't just look at the obvious
path
look at how maybe you could do other
things to help that path maybe your path
is that's the right way to go but maybe
you can look at you know these meant to
say this combination is like ah you have
and boost that path on yeah so that's
really one of the
have you done your launch pad with with
the when you first join the Academy you
know when you do your mentoring session
we know you've done that yeah it's how
we call it yes sorry what what happened
there what did you strategy change no I
don't think so I think we would quite
set on our strategy yeah if there's a
new strategy wants to initially you said
you wanted to save up money by by two
let's but then you thought actually
that's quite a slow that's gonna take a
long time to get to my goal of 150 grams
yeah yes like a long time so what what
is your strategy now then what are you
doing so we're just taking on more rent
two essays and then we also once we've
got maybe a couple more and we're
comfortable with it we'll start really
pressing ahead we're getting these by
refurbishment finance deals and putting
their money out yeah and put it put it
into like something tangible instead of
just you know because I'm always quite
you do get that the fact that these are
other people's properties and if they
whatever reason they don't want to do it
with you anymore they can you know they
can pull out all this so you say you
want to create as much cash flow as you
can but then put that money into
something that's more slow pound where
you're going to be able to actually own
it yes sure yeah that's brilliant have
you made many friends on the Academy
yeah yeah I think it's one of the best
things I even sometimes just want to put
post in the group like how much I love
working with the Academy he's so
friendly yeah and I we we had a problem
we've got a few problems every really as
you everyone does and you're not finding
Courtney up and she's like don't worry
about Jack's really friendly you're
great you know if everybody's brilliant
so yeah yeah it's really real family
that's what I love about it yeah cuz I
think you're the you're the makeup of
the people you spend the most time with
and I think it's so important to have if
you want to be financially free but you
haven't got any friends that are
financially free all your friends are in
jobs yeah but you want to be then then
you can't really expect to become
financially free so I think that mean
it's so important of people around you
they're cheering you on absolutely yeah
our friends nobody understands no faking
it was a lot of people
your well your family and stuff what do
they think of you doing this well my
family's very supportive supportive
again they just think you save up all
your life for a house yeah yeah they're
supportive of you but they just don't
get it
yeah I guess some of the even some of my
friends who I think might get it they
might they just don't yeah yeah yeah and
they're looking out for you it's just
that they don't understand yeah and what
when you say don't get it how would you
explain that it's like what what what
don't they get well it's different
avenues yeah yes yeah I think they think
they think like be sort of the old way
thing you need to put money into a
pension and yeah I get that but this is
like you're thinking yeah four weeks ago
yeah the way I explained it to them is
like you don't know what happens gonna
have a pension like it sounds secure but
really at the end of the day some people
it happens quite a lot in the companies
reduce that pension or mean you don't
have to be can't pay into it as well or
you're getting it when we're 95 yeah
exactly so you know for me and and I was
really I suppose is because we we're
working this is our business this is our
pension we we control it all yeah it's a
lot more secure for us yeah and a lot
better yeah what's your strongest reason
why why are you really doing this I'd
say most of the security yes yeah I
think security is the one yeah just
enjoying do you need something together
yeah got our own different businesses
and it's just nice to I've got we've got
a slightly insane goal of 10 years time
I want to be in Beverly Hills yeah have
you visited that yeah gold videos it
sounds crazy but now I'm gonna like a
big goal to go further
so what Beverly Hills just looks amazing
like the house is a brilliant and
they've got like all these it just looks
like every day is like a holiday yeah
it's a beautiful place
yeah so what do you think is next video
how many serviced accommodation
properties are you gonna get before you
start then putting the money into your
own portfolio
I'm kind of thinking it's kind of hard
for us to say we're kind of still
testing the waters yes I depend on how a
tough we find to manage these because
they always gonna take some management
yes and so maybe two or three more on
top of these two yeah I mean the fact
that he's been making this the sort of
money that we've talked about in January
because we all know January is the quiet
month
yeah and January is the month when I
mean that that's pretty impressive you
must have found a real gold one area
yeah we yeah we how did you come to find
in the area where how did you choose the
area and I mean you live in Manchester
and your patch is Liverpool but not just
Liverpool but a particular area yeah how
did you find that just lots of research
really but and speaking to letting
agents and yeah just really just putting
yourself out there going for it and then
you just learn it and the it's insane
really like like these tiny areas will
work amazingly well but then just a
little bit out it just works okay yeah
yeah yeah but you pick well you get and
how do you pick where they see you so
speak to letting agents yes so any
letting agent or a particular type of
letting agent what do you say to them we
you well we did we didn't use kind of a
butchered version of your script because
we but yeah we because we thought oh
these letting agents they're gonna they
just want to get to the point so instead
of going through a lot of the spiel we
just said look really other fun yeah
which is what we do right yeah yeah
which is tell us what you say so on the
let an agent you ring me what's the
first thing yeah I don't know you from
Adam yeah that's the phone what do you
say so we before we go we just took it
inspiration from your financial freedom
video isn't it yeah yeah we'd phone you
up and say oh hi my name is Chris I
usually buy rental houses I also you
know like buy rent out apartments yeah
and as a short term let's do you have
anything that anybody who could benefit
from this and go through the benefits
for them really yeah and that way if
they're not interested you think oh we
don't do that then you've wasted 20
seconds of your time
yeah whereas if you go view the property
first and try and get in through the
back door you can end
wasting so much time absolutely yeah and
I think the reason you guys have been so
successful is because you've just
followed exactly the script
yeah you've obviously seen the financial
freedom challenge you've been inspired
by that but then you come to the
training you're on the academy
yeah when if you get stuck you ask
people on the Academy yeah you ask me
you were you were on the front row at
lead generation masquerade asking the
questions and I think that's the reason
probably you've been so successful so
far which is fantastic would you agree
yeah I think so yeah just really just
using all UV sources yeah advantage and
like the academies brilliant you know
yeah the people were I was saying like
just so good yeah are so helpful yeah we
we would probably got got a bit forgot
got almost as far but maybe we would've
had a lot more problems and maybe you
would have to take your foot off the gas
because we'd be able to answer they you
know talk to you guys to answer all the
questions yeah if we weren't part of a
Academy but because we are the Academy
is an investment so it's not a cost it's
an investment yeah you've invested in
yourself and then it's paying off in
dividends so yeah you can try and cut
corners and you can try and cheapskate
it but if you want to be an IT
consultant you can either try and figure
out on your own but oh yeah or you just
get the professional training and then
get results are you gonna be a doctor or
hairdresser or a cook you need to do the
training which is what you've done so
and I think you can start by watching
YouTube videos and reading books but
ultimately if you're not around people
and you know actually doing it in a
community I think it's really really
difficult in the Academy these mentoring
went to sa deals and pay Fellows in four
or five months that's a 12-month program
paid for in five months
yeah and no one can ever take away their
knowledge from you either yeah yeah
absolutely yeah no one can take that
from you so no that's great so what how
do you manage your time then because
you're both you're running a business
you're an IT consultant very yeah very
busy job and quite a high-pressure job
what I imagine
yeah can be yeah so how do you you know
you've set up these properties with very
little money
we're talking two thousand pounds for
you know got college money to set the
property you like to put a lot of time
into it how have you found the time to
do that well we just literally spends
every spare minute
the systemize as much as possible so
what kind of what kind of sacrifices
have you had to make over the last few
months so I don't play my xbox and we
used to play your xbox yeah yeah just go
all out yeah that's interesting so
you've you've stopped playing on the
Xbox going out and eating our different
things and now you're calling just eat
it's a temporary thing it's not yeah of
course it's temporary but but it's it
will pay off in it when it is it's
already paid off in dividends yeah yeah
so how long were you gonna do plan on
working really hard on the property
business for before you know beginning
to yeah so IT consultant why do you
think we have so many IT consultant
turning to property at the moment well
they know a lot of them in quite good
money and they won't be spending it all
so yeah you know they'll be looking at
ways they can invest that money because
a lot of them do want to invest invest
their money for the future and look so
this government legislation called ir35
that's it's coming into a stronger force
in next April so they're currently they
in the public sector they in thought
they changed it from the contractor
having to disclose if they're part there
are ir35 complaining inside our 35 or
outside buy of 85 whereas now they put
it on the the company so they'd like the
NHS for instance they they will blanket
say everyone who works was is inside the
i-85 so these these IT consultant are
getting taxed heavily almost well more
than a full-time employee and so in
April next year this well then looking
only looking likely that they'll bring
it to the the private sector as well so
we don't know what's gonna happen they
may do this blanket you know we're
private companies might blanket again
say yet you're all inside 35 at which
point yeah we will get text a lot more
and yeah I lose a lot of money
yeah so there's probably a lot of
uncertainty amongst your your peers as
well yeah I bet about I bet a lot of
your peers are watching with interest or
even intrigue potentially because if if
in April the rules change and you
suddenly get massively taxed you won't
be affected so much because you've got a
property income coming in yeah but for
some people that are living off of that
off of that salary it's gonna really
hurt isn't it oh absolutely yeah yeah
huge amounts it goes you know they're
having getting taxed 20 to 25 percent
more straightaway and a lot of my
friends who are own consultants they'll
be there all you're talking about going
full-time because it's it's better to be
full-time yeah get all the benefits I
guess no job is is safe really is it we
grow up to think pay off the mortgage as
quickly as possible get a good job for
life retire get a pension but actually
these things aren't necessarily sensible
where they they seem sensible yeah but
it's more sensible to have a business
being entrepreneur to invest in property
yourself which is what you're doing
isn't it
yeah where you in control then where is
it if you put it to a company there that
you really rely on them to yeah to give
you all the benefits and if they decide
to take them away and it has no lots of
companies do that sometimes yeah
especially when there's like a credit
crunch or something like that and you
know they they get affected so if you
don't control your own life and control
your own economy someone else will yeah
and if someone else is controlling your
finances and in your future that's not
that's not a very pleasant thought
really no no I told no yeah because
you're just thinking what could happen
you don't you just don't know D say yeah
and I think the key is to probably get
educated because the reason people can't
take responsibility of their own life
and their own finances is because they
don't understand how to intuit invest
they don't understand a business they
don't understand entrepreneurship don't
understand property so they just think
oh I'll just get a pension I'll just
have a job cuz it's nice so I mean would
you think the key really is to get
educated and
I mean specifically for IT you know you
took in five six grand for an it one
course and it might not bring that much
more you know money in really where's
like you know something like the Academy
not too much more than that but like
it's a massive you you're set for life
instead of just like having one course
so it to me it's a no brainer yeah
presumably you're offsetting the costs
of your education that you're spending
on property against your property
business as well
so all the training costs that you're
investing out are tax-deductible right
absolutely yeah yeah yeah fantastic
yes one way we've invested into property
actually because we own this
self-employed we can do intercompany
loans in between okay so how does that
work so basically the money comes in to
Company A and you just do a loan from
company a to your property company and
at some point you need to pay that back
and we're going through the accountants
to at the moment to set up some sort of
holding company yeah I don't really
understand that they do do it so yeah
you can you can put that money into the
property company it's still got still
got paid tax on come through the IT
company but yeah it's just directly
instead of you got to go out and take
pay tax on it and put it back in yeah
you saved a lot of money on tax makes
sense makes a lot of sense I also think
that knowledge is important Network as
well and having people like good
accountants solicitors yeah to be able
to make the business work and happen
it's not about being really smart
yourself but having smart people around
you is really important so yeah yeah
those accountants when I make like I
don't understand what you're saying yeah
sounds like gold yeah so what advice
would you give them to someone that was
watching this video that was considering
setting up a business a property
business or being an entrepreneur that
wanted to take control of their own
future and finances what advice would
you give them their first steps which
really get educate yourself it's a
classic thing to say but you know if you
don't start setting all these things up
or do it wrong and then really screw
yourself over so if you don't just pay
small amount or you can go on a freak
crash-course like yours you'll be so far
ahead and you will not be so mom
prepared then then if you didn't do that
so yeah education is key really yeah
yeah I'm just like what I think a lot of
people say that but the reason I say is
because it's ro yeah absolutely right
yeah yeah I mean I would like you were
saying I wouldn't know you wouldn't
expect someone to go into IT security
without any training so why go into
pockets without any training yeah
absolutely brilliant well I really
appreciate you coming down very very
enlightening hearing from you and look
forward to working with you for the next
11 months and yeah my name is Samuel
Leeds thank you for watching winners on
a Wednesday every single week we
interview a success students for your
inspiration you can watch more right
here on the playlist as a whole playlist
of them so what you'll notice is every
single winner on a Wednesday always
starts with them coming to my 2-day
crash course so if you would like to be
a winner on a Wednesday literally come
on my crash course and who knows in
three months time you could be here in
my offices on this show as a winner on a
Wednesday so get yourself hooked on the
crash course watch more have fun I'll
see you next week